yes and that jargon you know is I mean
it's actually pretty accurate I mean
it's it's to my ear it sounds a holding
space but but there but I came to
appreciate it because what's happening
in these experiences is a when it's a
high dose therapeutic experience you you
are your ego may well be dissolving and
with it your defenses right we have
these defenses that are serve us there
get in our way too but they serve us and
to to feel comfortable putting down all
your defenses you have to feel really
safe and if you do that in the wrong
setting
and you fight to hold on to your sense
of self and your defense this is when
you get paranoid and have a really awful
experience so it takes a certain skill
it takes a certain compassion and meri
kasam oh no hasn't more than probably
anybody to to create that space where
you you feel comfortable enough to put
down every defense you have built up
over the course of your life it's a huge
gesture of trust and great things can
come from it
but it will only come in the right
setting